la saison passe et ils sont toujours là
leur météo c'est la colère qui les porte
depuis l'automne dernier une colère que
beaucoup estiment renforcée depuis les
orientations annoncées par emmanuel
macron jeudi des propositions jugées par
les gilets jaunes vide sans contenu sans
avancée concrète c'est plus de la
déception du foutage de gueule carrément
il nous prend vraiment pour des cons
déconne vous n'avez rien quoi même pas
de mesure et on attendait pas grand
chose mais rien et puis rien mais
vraiment rien voilà la coupe est pleine
pour ces manifestants qui ne retiennent
même pas une mesure
c'est un rejet pur et simple comme si
président est gêné jaune n'avait jamais
été sur la même longueur d'onde
c'est du bla basse et c'est vraiment
bien on ne bouge pas la retraite oui
mais on cotise plus longtemps donc ça
revient au même
donc la colère est toujours la même et
puis au niveau finance niveau budget il
n'y a rien dit a pas d'augmentation n'y
a rien donc on continue dans le schéma
qu'on jettera pas on continue nous on ne
lâchera rien lui peut-être qu'ils
lâchent rien non plus mais il faut être
bloqués par les forces de l'ordre la
préfecture
le gilet jaune ont réitéré leur volonté
de poursuivre leur combat
à belfort plus de 200 manifestants ont
également défilé aujourd'hui malgré
l'interdiction préfectorale
[Musique]